as our Nafisi where did you get the
title reading Lolita in Tehran
it was while I was writing my book on
Nabokov in Iran and I kept feeling that
this is a new reading of Nabokov because
of my life in Tehran and I wanted to
explain Tehran through through Lolita
and Lolita through Tehran why Lolita
well I felt at that point that my life
in Iran and the life of many like me
were Lolita could have been a metaphor
for it and Ayatollah comes to Iran and
likes to impose his dream upon our
reality turning us into his figments of
imagination and that is what Lolita is
basically about the crime of ellipses I
think another person's life when in the
Nabokov or Nabokov right Lolita
he wrote it some in early 50s and there
was a great deal of scandal about it he
thought that he could never publish it
under his own name so at first it was
published in France and then there was
quite a fairer over it in England and us
and finally Graham Greene gave it
credibility by choosing it as one of the
best books he had read that whereas is
Nabokov so long no he died in
Switzerland in 1977 where was he from
originally he was from Russia and he was
born on the last year of 1919 century
1899 and he claimed that according to
one Russian calendar his birthday was
the same as Shakespeare's 23rd of April
what's the story of Lolita about the
story of Lolita is about this very
sophisticated articulate European man 38
who in his childhood falls in love with
this girl when he was 13 Annabel Lee and
she dies and their love is never
consummated and ever since then he
becomes obsessed with the image of
Annabel Lee and when he meets Lolita
years later he tries to turn that little
girl into his dead Annabel Lee
and he said uses and rapes her and keeps
her under his yoke for two years until
she finally escapes she was how old
again
12 she was 12 does that have any
relationship to the fact that in Tehran
you say today or in Iran that men can
marry a woman at age 9 yes they lured
after the Revolution they lowered the
age of marriage from 18 to 9 and I
always felt a nine year old girl her
life has not started yet and when you
marry her off to a man like Lolita you
are confiscating her childhood and that
is to me one of the biggest crimes
how often do women nine years old or
girls nine years old marry in Iran what
I tell you actually I'm rather proud of
the fact that many of the laws that the
government brought to Iran or imposed
upon the society didn't take off partly
because Iran was so advanced and people
would not you know act accordingly but
there are many young girls who are
married and there was actually an
official report on many of the young
girls who died yearly because of early
marriage you know how about the is it
true that a man can have four wives yes
yes it is true that the man can have
four wives these are all the laws that
came back in the name of religion which
I think was abusive religion as an
ideology what about temporary wives and
what are temporary yeah according to
some Shia doctrines or tradition and in
Iran this is practiced a man can marry
any number of women he desires from they
have a contract and that contract can be
from five minutes to 99 years but so you
can have a wife you travel to another
city you want a temporary wife
I think it's legalized prostitution to
tell you the truth how many years have
you lived in the United States versus
how many years you lived in Iran well I
came to the United States
during the last year of my high school
and I left it after I got my PhD I left
the US in 79 and I stayed in Iran for 18
years before I left in 97 before that I
was in Iran until I was 13 and then I
went to England for my high school where
did you live in the United States where
did you go to school there's a long
story behind that I wouldn't bore you
with it but I got married at a very
young age before I turned 18 to a man
who was going to engineering school at
the University of Oklahoma and that's
where I went and that's where I stayed
where'd you get your PhD everything was
in Oklahoma and the PhD was in what the
PhD was in English and American
literature and I wrote my dissertation
on someone that many Americans don't
know about Mike gold and the proletarian
writers of the 1930s go back to when you
were at the University of Oklahoma you
talk about protesting and being
activists and all what were you
protesting well you know very few people
know that University of Oklahoma at
Norman was very active during the
Vietnam and the student protests but in
the last year's that I stayed in US I
got involved in the student movement in
the Iranian student movement against the
Shah and that movement was very active
all across Europe and United States I
remember myself in front of White House
saying CIA agents u.s. advisors out of
Iran and then they were out and what
year were you doing this that was in
late 70s in 76 77 why did you want the
Shah out well at the time the way I felt
about it of course this part of it I
still believe in I felt that we did not
have enough right to political
participation and certainly the Iranian
Society what was advanced enough for
people to want that and I was against
the political oppression and that
existed in Iran at the time but I feel
that I myself and the student movement
we were to idealogical ourselves so I
needed to criticize my own part you know
in the movement it is not enough to be
against tyranny you yourself have to
choose different methods to confront it
for the moment let me just jump ahead to
where are you now
I'm now at Washington DC I mean I live
in Potomac Maryland with my family but I
teach and I have a project at the School
for Advanced International Studies Johns
Hopkins in Washington DC what
citizenship do you hold I know have a
green card is that the way you're going
to keep it I mean that means you're
still an Iranian citizen I'm still an
Iranian citizen I I say at the end of
the book that I feel that my world like
what Nabokov talks about has become a
portable world a set of books a set of
principles and the people I love you
know so the world has become very small
being here I don't feel as if I'm not in
contact with my own country you know or
with my own people say the first
marriage ended in divorce how long were
you married I was married for I'm very
bad with dates that's why I'm pausing
for about almost three and a half years
my father at that time was in jail in
Iran and I didn't want him to worry
about me and my personal life so
actually as soon as he came out of jail
I got divorced what was he doing in jail
previously he had been the mayor of
Tehran and he was a rather popular mayor
and he was also very stubborn and so
they put him in jail without a trial for
four years and then at his trial he
defended himself and he was exonerated
of all the charges except one which was
insubordination and I love that now I
went through a lot of despair then hate
to keep doing this but the years that he
was in jail when was he mayor of Tehran
from 1961 to 1963 so who was it they put
him in jail well he ran into a lot of
problems with both the Minister of
Interior who was his superior and the
price
minister at that time and of course
without the Shahs consent that would not
have happened and one of the things that
saved him later on during the Revolution
was that when Ayatollah Khomeini led his
first rebellion against the Shah in
early 60s against the right of women to
vote and a series of reforms that the
Shah had brought my father was mayor and
he opened the hospitals to people who
were being wounded and he tried to you
know sort of take care of the protesters
and that went into his file so during
the Islamic Revolution at least he was
spared back to the present for a moment
you're still married to bhishan I'm
married to bhishan I married him in
September of 1977 two children two
wonderful children their age and what do
they do my daughter Niger is now 19 and
she goes to University of Maryland she's
studying molecular biology she wants
double major English Lit and molecular
biology my son Dara is last year of high
school and he's going to go to Virginia
Tech and he wants to follow his father's
path which is engineering
why did you in the first place at the
University of Oklahoma get interested in
American literature I was as long as I
remember I loved literature and books
this is the only snob ism my family ever
you know claimed my father all through
my childhood told me stories from
Iranian clack classical tales that is
how we communicate if he didn't like one
thing I did he put it in a tale about
this man whose little daughter and books
are my life I don't remember any time I
wasn't interested
lady you broke your book into four parts
Lolita was the first part and then you
also talked about Jane Austen and you
talked about Henry James and there was
one other section Fitzgerald Gary Gatsby
why did you break the book into fours
what was the point
well actually I felt that I mean there
are so many other books and writers that
are my favorite but I divided these
books into sort of the times of my life
and I wanted to concentrate on books
that explained these periods in my life
you know sort of carried the rhythm of
the life I spent in Iran and Nabokov as
I said is about confiscation of an
individual's life and how individuality
is at the center of what we call freedom
today the James is about ambiguity and
how to Attalla terian mindsets hate
ambiguity they like black and white
Gatsby is about the American Dream and
our own dreams of revolution and how it
was shattered and Austin is about choice
a woman at the center of the novel
saying no to the authority of her
parents society and welcoming a life of
dire poverty in order to make your own
choice so that is how I divided them but
many other books should have been there
when I finish the book I also thought
you could have named this book for an
American audience the veil yes or there
was an article I wrote in The New
Republic it was called the veiled threat
you are right it does have many I mean
veil has many connotations
the most obvious one being the cloth
that women wear but it is also about the
veils that society in politics and we
ourselves create and how freedom is
being the ability to confront not only
the veil that society creates for you
but the veils that you create inside
yourself the ability or the courage to
faced up to them how long did the Shah
run Iran and when did he leave he lived
he ruled for almost 25 years and he left
Iran in 1978 and that was the time when
Shah left and how many came came back to
Iran he
how many left Iran in early 1960s after
he protested against the Shahs White
Revolution and reforms where did how
many come from back to her Iran where
did well most of his life his life in
exile he spent in Iraq actually but the
last part of it him Saddam Hussein was
making some deals apparently with the
Iranian government and life for how many
in Iraq was becoming a little hard so he
went to France and this little village
called no flesh-eater which became so
famous where everybody would go to visit
him and I think that is what made how
many how many that is what made him so
well known would all the meat it was
some people say it was the first
revolution in the media through the
media you know how much attention did he
get when he was in France oh he got
amazing attention because first of all I
think that figure of this stately
Ayatollah sitting under the apple tree
in no flesh Chateau was a very very
attractive image and how many himself
was a very charismatic personality and
then many people made sort of
pilgrimages to where he was you know
whether they were Islam Muslim or not
and this was a very attractive image for
for the media and the image of the
tradition taking over this modernization
I think that aspect of it also was
attractive as you know we've heard a lot
about Iraq in the last couple years but
go back to home aney living in Iraq he
was a Shiite I assume and Saddam Hussein
was a Sunni asylum yeah what's the
difference for you can you explain it to
the the person that no it doesn't know
the background on which I wouldn't like
to do that because I'm not an expert and
anyone else would be able to you know
anyone who is really an expert in Islam
would be able to explain it better but I
know that for my own country first of
all Iran was Sunni until about 400 years
ago when we had
dynasty the the a bossy the Safavid who
as against the Ottoman Empire created
turned around into a Shia Empire with
its own peculiarities in order to
differentiate so it was not all
political it was also it was not all
religious it was also political but one
of the main differences for example
between Shia and Sunni is that the she
adds the Sunnis believe that after the
Prophet died the the people they chose
they chose his his successors while they
Shiites basically believed that the
right of his nephew and his right-hand
man
Ali was you know sort of confiscated by
these others Abu Bakr Omar and Osman who
succeeded him and that Ali was his
rightful successor they also believed
that in the 12 Imams who who sort of
continued Muhammad's dynasty while the
Sun is only believed until the seventh
Imam I think that partly the difference
for Iranians definitely definitely it
was to differentiate themselves from the
Islam that was brought into their
country they wanted to create their own
independent identity and I think that
that is part of it we learned during the
Iraqi work a lot about populations that
Iraq had something around 24 million
depending on what day it is how big is
Iran well Iran has almost doubled since
the revolution started so it is near 70
million and they share the same border
they share the same border but not the
same language no no Iran is Persian they
like to call it Farsi I I think like
English you say English I say Persian
and Iraqis are Arabic what's the
difference between the two languages
well the roots of
is in the European and we're after the
Arab invasion of I think that was maybe
the most complete invasion our country
had been invaded many times but that was
the most complete invasion of the
country where the Arabic language so
much entered Persian and mixed was mixed
with Persian so you cannot understand
Persian grammar without understanding
the Arabic grammar there are still
certain letters which are Persian
version has more letters than Arabic al
does so while I can when I look at the
letters in Arabic I can understand them
but I can't understand the language
Persian is closer to the order which is
what for example is being spoken in
Afghanistan actually all do is a pure
form of language than the Iranian
version of it you know they have when
the Ayatollah took over I assume that's
what you would say when he came back
during the Revolution happened in in
1979 yes what happened to women what
changed for women wants the Ayatollah
and the fundamentalist took over uh you
know Iran and I don't like to say that
it was just the Shah who brought us
freedom because it's not true I mean
ordered rights of women Iran since there
are like many other countries in its
neighboring his vicinity like Turkey
like Egypt like Lebanon near the end of
19th century Iran and ruined a great
deal of social and cultural and
political turmoil because of the crisis
within the country itself it couldn't
hold on to the old despotism and one of
the things that happened was women
wanted to become more visible the first
woman who unveiled in Iran it was in mid
nineteenth century a woman named Tahiry
who was also the leader of one of the
now new religions Barbie religion which
later turned into Baha'i religion which
was an offshoot of Islam you know and
then with the constitutional revolution
women by-and-bye started fighting for
their rights to public education and
you know otherwise so by the time of the
Revolution we had women senators - women
ministers one of them my old high school
principal who was murdered by the regime
a woman from mint women Minister for
women's affairs we had the right to vote
we had women in all walks of life but
your mother yes my mother was also one
of she was too outspoken to last but she
was one of the first women along with
that high school principal who went to
the Parliament in early in 1961 and what
happened was that the first thing that
the Islamic regime did before they had a
new constitution was to repeal the
family protection law which which
protected the rights of women at home
and at workplace they lowered the age of
marriage and they brought back the
Sharia laws which contains stoning for
adultery Sharia is the law of Islam yeah
it is not the law that is in kora it is
the law that was created afterwards and
if you look at the Constitution of Iran
is far opener society than Afghanistan
was for example or Saudi Arabia is but
the laws are very similar there are the
same punishments for for the same crimes
and women became the center of attack
the the everything I mean the way I look
now was all of a sudden a symbol of the
West and unfortunately some people in
the West also call me not Iranian but
westernized which I very much resented
so if you went to Tehran right now and
got on an airplane and start to land
there what would you change what would
change for you that you can't that you
can do here
of course now Iran because of the
especially the young people's rebellion
is much more open in that and when I
left it in 97 but first of all I have to
cover my hair I have to wear a scarf
that would you have to cover your entire
well this is the law nowadays they're
much more relaxed because they couldn't
control it but the way these girls are
on the cover of my book the
that even is not really proper you know
you should wear cover the hair properly
but nobody does that in Iran today why
did you choose this for the cover it's
so much reminded me of my own students
the sort of simplicity and it seems as
if they're reading a book you know and I
the youth and I wanted the cover to be
very simple and I'm very grateful to
Random House for finding that where was
that actually taken you know they they
got it from you know they bought it from
a company which sold these photographs
are they to Iranian girls yeah they're
to Iranian girls they're very similar to
my own students so you land in Tehran
right now you put the veil on and then
you you have to you see the point is
that the contours of your body should
not be shown so you have to wear
something like a raincoat or a rope or
or a chador which covers your whole body
yeah you're not supposed to have makeup
on at all no no you see the philosophy
behind it is that women should not
attract attention because women become
sources of temptation which is rather
paradoxical because women are so active
in Iran and they are there so one of the
things that really bothered me was that
I was asked to be visible because I went
to work the way I do to here at the same
time I was asked to be invisible because
I couldn't talk I couldn't shake hand
with my male students or my male
colleagues ever no no you cannot touch a
man who is not related who is not like
your father your brother or your husband
you know you cannot show your hair or
other parts of your body to that to that
man now from day one women rebelled
against this there were demonstrations
were hundreds of thousands of Iranian
women came into the streets and said no
to the veil they had to make it
mandatory at workplace to begin with
then they made it mandatory in shops
then they made it mandatory in public as
a whole and since I left Iran I see
pictures of my own students
women walking down the streets of Tehran
a lot has changed because this new
generation is not going to take it you
know what about you can't eat ice cream
the one I talk about in the book yeah
but eating well any like for example
licking ice cream in public is sort of
called decadent or unseemly for a woman
and my daughter's school wearing
shoelaces that were colored were not
allowed Reeboks were not allowed wearing
a certain kind of trendy eyeglasses were
not allowed and I think this is not
really religion I mean you know my
grandmother always were the way till the
day she died and during the shafts
father's reign for one for three months
they made the taking off of the whale
mandatory she refused to leave home for
three months so the issue in Iran right
now as in other Muslim societies is
choice nobody should choose for me how
to worship my God how to relate to my
god you know now the veil unfortunately
has become a political token not a token
of faith you lived in Tehran during the
iraq-iran war what years will was the
war they started right after I came to
Iran I think the war in Iran started in
1979 and went on until nineteen nineteen
eighty seven it went war for eight years
one of the years and it may have been 87
I can't remember you say there were a
hundred and sixty-seven missiles yeah
that's was fired by a rock into Tehran
or the entire country up no Tehran
Tehran as first was not as much targeted
now the parts that they started
targeting where the oil-rich parts which
were close to Iran to Iran that was the
cities of Abaddon and garam chef
they really almost demolished those
cities then they started on the bigger
cities and Tabriz in the northern part
Isfahan and Tehran
and the hardest attack on Terra was
those last few months before the war
ended whoo it started the war Saddam did
he he bombed an oil refinery and that is
I was I remember we had come from a
vacation from Caspian and we turned on
the radio and they said that the war has
started but Iran also at that time Iran
was provoking a lot of the Muslims not
just in Iran but also in Saudi Arabia
and the neighboring countries
every time there was a pilgrimage to
Makkah Iranians were starting death to
America and calling these regimes
puppets of us so it all was very
politically active at that time were you
religious I felt that I was really just
not in terms of you know following any
specific rules my parents my mother went
to the pilgrimage she never wore the
veil my father considered himself
religious for a while when I was in
states I thought I was a martyr but like
the fact that I thought I was Marxist
and I was reading Gatsby all the time I
thought I was a Marxist and at nights I
would from since childhood I had a
conversation with God which was very
personal and that's how my father taught
me religion should be the converse a
series of conversations with God so you
weren't an Islam member of the Islam no
religion no I wasn't but some nobody in
Iran was in that way and you know
mosques you didn't go to church mosque
away you went to the church you know by
the way in a Islamic Society what are
the women do if only men go to the
mosque yet the women and after the
Islamic Revolution in Iran for example
the women would sit behind the curtains
or would sit at one other section where
they're not seen but before the Islamic
Revolution it was very individual Act
people would sometimes go to mosque for
prayer or especially the Friday's
prayers were very important but it was
not
you know action at all and at any rate
whether at mosque or at home women were
always sort of segregated in one sense
ayatollah khomeini paradoxically brought
traditional women much more into the
society because he discovered how
amazingly helpful they are when Shah
granted the right to vote to women in
early 60s Ayatollah Khomeini called that
an act of prostitution and he gave a an
edict against it when he came to Iran
and with all these women in the streets
that he could in no way put them back he
realized what a goldmine he had a very
very intelligent man you know in the
beginning of your book you have an
author's note and you say aspects of
characters and events in this story have
been changed mainly to protect
individuals not just from the eye of the
censor but also from those who read such
narratives to discover who's who and who
did what to whom are any of these names
reflected with the people that you knew
the names know their lives yes the names
I tried some of the names rhyme some of
the names rhyme and you know what
happened with the seven girls what
happened is that I consulted with one of
my girls whom I call mana I said what
name what name would you want you know
and then she gave me the name that she
wanted and her husband and then we
played with the names and we try to find
names that would sort of resonate with
their personality and with their
character some of the names are true my
student who was killed in Chapter three
Razia I had no reason to not use her
name anymore how was she killed Madeline
she was of course I didn't know about
that I found out later she belonged to a
radical Muslim organization the
Mujahideen actually at the beginning a
lot of people young people at the
beginning just were affiliated with
these organizations without much knowing
what they were and she was arrested in
early 80s and later on executed I heard
about her from
another student who was in jail with her
and she told me you know in jail we
talked I told her about Gatsby and she
told me about James so I wondered where
my books go you know not just in classes
but in prison houses who killed her the
government in those days they executed a
lot of people and they were very gung-ho
about it it was it is now that they
don't sort of announce it I remember
that after one demonstration they had
the pictures after you executed the
front page of the papers they felt that
this would be a warning to those who you
know my own cousins were executed
actually for wild for being politically
active against the regime for
participating in demonstrations that I
remember about a 12 year old girl who
was distributing leaflets and that
became well-known and my students were
talking about it to where she was
running around while they were trying to
catch her to execute her asking for her
mother and another thing that happened
was virgins supposedly go to heaven if
they're killed and some of these
leftists and radicals who were arrested
the guards would quote Hanko temporarily
marry them in order that they won't be
virgins when they go to heaven these are
the things that will always remain and
these are the things that I feel
complicit in - although I wasn't part of
it you know you taught at two
universities in Tehran
what were they I started teaching at the
University of Tehran until I was
expelled well here was the experiment I
I was they expelled me in 81 or 82 the
reason I'm not sure about it is that at
some point in 1980 I stopped going
and they kept writing me letters
and because I didn't want to wear the
mandatory weight and then one day they
just said wrote it you know sent me an
edict saying that you're expelled all
because of the veil what I wouldn't wear
it and you couldn't go to work without
the way and I know that later I was
forced to veil it to wear it and a
colleague told me why are you doing this
because tomorrow you'll be forced to
wear it in grocery stores and I said to
her that University is not a grocery
store and if my students up to now have
seen me without the veil and they see me
with the veil tomorrow for just leased
out money that I'll be getting monthly I
want them to remember at least that
there was a protest here you know and I
didn't teach until mid 80 mid 1980s
I did go temporarily just for a term or
two teaching at a free Islamic
University and the Shaheed Beheshti
University and then I chose this one the
one
Aloma Tabata by a university because I
felt it was quote-unquote more liberal
what happened at that school well of
course you know what what the image you
have of liberal and the image I have at
that time as liberal is different but
that school was an amalgamation of about
23 small colleges and universities that
they put together so they were not so
centralized at the a Lamia and we had
more leeway if you had a good head of
the department or head of the faculty
there were things you could do that you
couldn't do in other places so when I
went there I remember the first thing
they told me they said we know about
your veil problem you know so promises
that you will do that and I said this is
not the law of the land I have no choice
but I will teach what I want to and
until I stayed there despite all the
problems I had with them they kept that
promise I thought what I wanted to teach
but they constantly harassed me the
classes became very popular and people
would come from all over to the classes
not because I'm so great but because I
was teaching the things that people were
hungry for
American literature American in English
did you teach in Farsi or did you know
anything in English oh yeah it was all
in English and you know they read Tom
Jones and withering Heights all of this
in English that is another thing I
wanted to tell about in this book in one
sense we were victims in another sense I
wanted people to understand how people
in the face of such oppression create
spaces themselves create spaces that
nobody can take from them and they were
so eager I never had such intense
classes so how did you decide to take
the seven students to your home
okay by mid-nineteenth against we went
through a process of the liberalisation
and the head of our faculty who was very
open and he had allowed me to do a lot
of programs there he was you know taken
off his job and they started again
talking from the veil - why are you
teaching these why are these people
coming to your class so I thought that
rather than concentrating on my nabokov
and my Austin I'm concentrating on how
far my veil is right now you know am I
to open with my students if the teacher
cannot teach that way and my dream was
to teach in a environment where we were
just in love with literature you know if
they took away a lot of things I could
create my own paradise you know and so
these girls of course there were a lot
more but some of them I'd had no access
to anymore
these girls were my most trusted girls
and most of them had finished school but
they kept auditing classes and one of
them was a freshman who audited my
graduate classes and she was wonderful
so I thought I would like to find the
seven that are most committed and I
couldn't have more because you wanted
interaction it was after all just in my
living room where did you live in tehran
i lived in the northern part of tehran
where you could see the mountains from
there
there used to be a lot of gardens around
it but every day I would leave the house
and one garden was done and one higher I
was going up how big was your home
well my home was not all that big my
parents were not as I mentioned we quote
unquote belong to the upper classes but
we were never very rich and the house
that we had before which was in the same
place my father sold that house and on
the part of the ground he built a
three-story apartment one for my mother
because my parents separated in early
80s one for my mother one for me and
sort of a bachelor's pad for my brother
so we had a two and a half bedroom
apartment but it was in a very good
place of their own I'm not trying to say
that yeah
and so what year was the first Thursday
morning session with the seven girls it
was the fall of 1995 and what was the
age range of the women students well my
youngest was about 19 almost between
almost 20 and the eldest were in their
early 30s because some of them like one
of them who is now here actually living
in California they had finished their MA
degree and they had just come to my
classes you know so and one of them she
had gone to jail for five years so she
had to restart going to school many
students in Iran had that trouble they
had to start late because of the jail so
when they showed up in 1995 at the door
did they have the veil on well that is
the wonderful thing they had the veil on
and then they take it off and they'll be
completely different people even the
ones who were practicing Muslim and had
and wore the veil because you know
before the Revolution women who were the
valent they didn't all were eat
uniformly I mean that wasn't communist
it's in communist China where everybody
wears things uniformly and I think this
regime used the veil the way China used
the uniform so under the
wait there'll be colors that was the
first thing I noticed the second thing I
noticed how hair makes a difference one
three of them I hadn't seen without
their base before and all of a sudden I
felt you know who is this is this to say
because your gestures change everything
about your changes when you become what
you think you are by the way the men
don't wear ties they weren't supposed to
I remember one slogan and one of the
walls in the streets where it said that
I'm wearing ties means you're an agent
of US imperialism
so actually you mentioned this I just
remembered it
we had a very stubborn and rebellious
professor at the University of Tehran
and he was really top in his field he
was a linguist and there was a
conference at the University of Tehran
and he refused not to wear his time and
there was a big to-do they couldn't
allow professors Rob and this professor
to come with his tie on you know and
they had to I can cancel his he was
professor botany and the reason I'm
using his name is because you know this
was open you know it's nothing to hide
they couldn't allow him to come with the
time I know of course men also
participated in this process of
rebellion the my father always wore a
coat and tie and they just didn't accept
it you know so right now could this book
that you wrote be sold in Tehran no no I
don't think so no way why not they would
I wouldn't think that I'm being
politically you know rebellious but they
would and also what you what I say you
know everything that is existential
became political because in this book I
talk about women I talk about culture
and and human rights and my whole
existence is right now political if I
walk down the streets of Tehran like
this I'm making a political statement
and this book is about that and I wanted
people over here to know that this is
not a cultural issue we don't like to be
genitally mutilated or be flogged
because we don't wear the veil our
cultures are poets and our great writers
and that I'm not political but if I want
to live as a woman or a writer or a
human being my existence is in danger in
their house you lived in where the seven
women met once a week yes for how long
two years there was an incident where
some Revolutionary Guards came into your
home yes
what was the story that that was almost
comic and this is the point that we had
to laugh at our own insecurities well we
had a neighboring apartment house where
apparently a couple lived and this guy
was who lived there who had antique cars
and actually he smoked opium as well we
could smell it it was discovered later
on that he belonged to this
assassination teams that the regime had
and within the regime they were
constantly fights between factions and
one date at first two revolutionary
girls showed up at our door and they
said that they want to use our back our
yard to jump into the neighbor's yard to
arrest this person and we wouldn't let
them and finally then four of them came
and they said that this guy has not
jumped into our yard and is hiding in
the yard with a gun and they want to
catch him so for over two hours or so
our balconies were used for you know
this exchange of gunfire until he jumped
into the other neighbor's house and they
found him finally caught him and what we
were worried about we had a satellite
dish and rather than thinking about our
lives we were thinking what will happen
if they find this forbidden sad like
couldn't have a satellite this of course
that you had their year in jail plus
monetary fine and we later on a house
was raided and they were nice to us
because they took our satellite dish
away but they didn't take us to jail
you know but so when they were there
that one time they saw the satellite
dish but they didn't take it that they
were so much worried about that guy and
they used there was this lady who helped
us watch with our children and they used
her as a shield one of them said that he
won't he won't shoot at you you know if
I keep doing front of me he won't he
won't shoot at you and it showed me how
absurd these people are and how
vulnerable I mean these two factions
fighting against one another you know
early in the book you tell us that the
sensor in Iran is blind well this is a
story that always remained with me and I
really wanted to have a chance to talk
about it the sense the main sensor
because there were more than one but
their main sensor for fail meant in 1994
was almost blind and before that my
friends told me he was the sensor for
theatres and after 1994 he became he
came the head of a channel a new
television channel and I always thought
you know we write fiction as metaphors
for reality but this is one place where
reality is its own metaphor what can I
say about this regime that would match
the blind sense search you know you use
the The Great Gatsby and Lolita and
Henry James and Jane Austen as one theme
through the book you also use the women
that you taught that came to your house
for two years as another thing to the
book then you have somebody called the
magician yes who was the magician well I
felt really lonely during those years
not just because of the political
situation but because there was so few
people with whom I could talk I mean I
could talk literature with my friends
and a lot and my students who were very
good at talking about it but I wanted
someone who who has really read this I
mean who is my match in terms of the
knowledge and you know and this magician
he wrote criticism literally and both
film and theater criticism when he was
in his early 20s and he run a magazine a
literary magazine which was very both
elitist and very prestigious and he also
taught at the University of Tehran until
the Revolution when the students took
over his faculty and they wanted to
replace Racine and Aeschylus and
Shakespeare would readings of Marx and
Engels he said that he will never teach
again because this is not what he's
there for
and so he stayed at home and a lot of
literary and film people would come to
him and ask him advice and that is how
he became friends I did he was the only
one who had written written about
Nabokov he had written about Nabokov
spilled fire and when they are just
called him to talk about it to him and
then you know until the day I left we
were friends now when you read the book
you talk to him a lot and my reaction
was what is old Bijan think of this
husband my husband who is one of the
most wonderful and secure men I have
ever met and like my first husband who
would say that he would have a revolver
under his bed in case you know our
relationship is a based on upon absolute
trust and I talked about visions
favorite book is Great Gatsby he's
rereading it again but you know he
didn't know about literature as much as
you know and we couldn't talk and so he
knew about the fact that we were very
good friends and there was nobody could
replace vision for me you know so so
where would you see the magician
uh one of the things we did we took long
walks because he liked his walk and we
would take even during snow how much
difference was there in your age I think
he was about eight years older than I
was and then sometimes I would go to his
home for
lunch or for you know coffee and we had
another friend who sometimes the three
of us and sometimes we all went to a
restaurant the three of us and I had a
couple who were bookstore owners who
were family friends as well and
sometimes we went to the mountains with
them you know how do you
how could you though go to a restaurant
when you're not allowed to look each
other in the eye well this is the
paradox of Iran and that is why I'm
saying that these guys are using
literature as an a religion as ideology
let me give you an example in buses in
Iran buses are segregated women are
supposed to sit behind me but in taxis
and minibuses women and men are sitting
on top of one another I mean there's not
enough room so you know so the fact is
that you see these contradictions in
Iran and a lot of the journalists who go
to Iran that is what gets them that the
laws are always behind the society
itself of course they also rate the
restaurants and once when I was there in
with my magician
they raided it and if they caught us
together despite the fact of my husband
knew and didn't mind it they could have
you know accuses of adultery just
because we were sitting do they still
have the morality patrols running around
the city and I don't think any more when
I was in Iran in 97 they still had them
but I'm talking with my friends and
students and they said that there is so
much unrest that they don't want to add
to people's dissatisfaction by having
the morality police around but they
still have great parties and raid houses
and every once in a while they raid the
streets there's one that you talk about
contradictions or strange things and all
page 71 of your book it's the Ayatollah
that you're talking about and you say
the Ayatollah himself was no novice in
sexual matters this is one of your
students at saying this she said I've
been translating his magnum opus the
political philosophical social and
religious principles of Ayatollah
Khomeini and he has some interesting
points to make I'm just going to jump to
the the pointers did you know that one
way to cure a man's sexual appetites
by having sex with animals how many
supposed to be scientist uh yeah this is
every Ayatollah at least in our in this
year they they give something like their
dissertation in order to become one and
there are set of questions that they
they think that they will be asked and
they have to answer and these are the
set of questions that he has and he
answers well let me read on I'll read it
again did you know that one way to cure
a man's sexual appetites is by having
sex with animals and then there's the
problem of sex with chickens yes you
have to ask yourself of a man who has
had sex with a chicken can then eat the
chicken afterwards our leader has
provided us with the answer no neither
he nor his immediate family are next to
our neighbors can eat of that chickens
meat but it's okay for the neighbor who
lives two doors away yeah you see this
is the problem I don't think that
Ayatollah how many really believed in
the kind of stuff that he wrote but this
is what he wrote and this is what they
have been writing for four hundred years
it's not just him and there was an
Ayatollah in Iran called golpea Gandhi
who was also the prosecutor at the
beginning of the Revolution and a very
ruthless one and he had a program where
he would talk about these issues on
television and one of the biggest jokes
about him was when he said that if there
is an earthquake and your aunt is
sleeping downstairs and you fall on top
of her and you have children then what
would happen and people in Iran made fun
of that I am Oh Jethro some good fire
going and they would call it the Gilly
show because people would listen to it
for laughs you know and this is such the
meaning of a great religion and you do
have people over here in this country
who are absolute fundamentalists and who
believe in a lot of you know very
strange things but you don't bring it
and make it the law of the land you know
haven't spent any time talking about
your students much and their
interrelation with the literature and
all but it might be interesting because
you do some of this in the epilogue you
had seven for two years came your home
every Thursday
where are those seven today this is 1997
when your broker 97 some of them
actually continued the class without me
and they're also one of them the
youngest one Yossi she created a class
of her own which was so wonderful that
when she got her finally her visa and
was accepted at the University here she
was wondering whether she should leave
or not
because of her class she wanted to be
like your uncle's all of whom lived and
came to us and got a degree while her
mother and her aunts could never do that
and Yossi was the first woman in her
family who is not getting a PhD at Rice
the other one our zine whom I talked
about whose husband was beating her up
and wouldn't let her see her three year
old girl she finally got her divorce and
she's married again and she lives in
Dublin California and she was at one of
my talks in San Francisco which was the
strangest thing seeing her look like
that in front of it another one Mitra is
in Canada she's going to an art school
and of mastering the one who had to
escape the borders I don't know where
she is and three of them are still in
Iran and my male student teaches and
still writes criticism which I hopefully
one day finish was the male student
there at all the meetings with me none
of them none of the means he would come
to my house you know on a one-to-one
basis I wrote this down when I read your
book I can't live like this anymore when
did you make that statement and leave
the country to tell you the truth for a
long time I kept saying it every year I
can't live like this anymore but this
class which was the highlight of my life
in Iran at least my working life in Iran
also made me realize how isolated I had
become I thought how long more can I
come can I continue with the class
it can't be forever with this seven
girls you know not six and I can't write
what I want because this book reading
Lolita in Tehran was in my mind for a
long time
I'm and when I would comfort walk
sinuous the title of my talks were a lot
of times reading Lolita and to tell you
the truth I wanted to write and teach
and I didn't have many years left you
know to do that so that was when I
decided to leave your children are 19
and 17 yes and you're teaching at Johns
Hopkins and how do you like it I like it
very much I was always worried about I
mean I'm about teaching here
I wondered if students would like janus
you know the way they did there I didn't
want to be disappointed I was very
pleasantly surprised currently this
class and today is the last day of that
class I'm teaching Zora Neale Hurston
side by side with Jane Austen the
classes I teach here do not have the
intensity of my classes in Iran I mean
people do not ruffle their hair reading
Nabokov but there is also a freedom and
a relaxedness about it which I enjoy I
sometimes think my students do not
appreciate what they have we only have a
few seconds will you ever go back and
live in Iran do you think I don't know I
would like to leave that option open I
would like to have a portable world and
I always dream of going back sometime
this is the cover of the book reading
Lolita in Tehran and memoir azar Nafisi
our guest I thank you very much thank
you so much